hey james
you're up 2-0 you won the first two
games double digits
do you feel like you're in control of
the series
uh no you know we played uh we played
well uh we didn't shoot the ball
particularly well tonight but i think
defensively
especially in that second half we did an
unbelievable job of just gearing in
on what they like to do and uh
correcting our uh
you know our mishaps in that first half
dan loki hey james uh to take you away
from the series real quickly sunday
would be
kobe's 43rd birthday i believe um
obviously
he looms so large in in this year for
the people who know him so much other
stuff has gone on but i'm just curious
kind of
how much do you think about your
friendship with him and
what has he meant to you kind of after
his passing how much do you think about
him and what do you think he would have
made of the situation you guys are in
now
in the bubble and all the competition uh
all the time
i think his his presence is just alone
because uh you know he made you feel him
um you know obviously when he spoke um
but just his impact obviously
on the court you know he was impacting
so many people uh with the game of
basketball
um his competitive nature his spirit
just everything is it was unbelievable
so i think about him a lot man and just
uh you know obviously
we all miss him you know what he's done
for individually he was like a role
model
to me man obviously i look up to him as
a basketball player when i was younger
you know you know growing up in la
and then as i got you know as he got
older on his way out of the league
he kind of became a real mentor uh you
know outside of basketball and in the
business aspect in the business world
um and so that's kind of you know where
our relationship really grew
thank you
james yesterday when mike was talking to
us he he talked about heart
will and character and a bunch of things
like that
how much of this of winning on a night
you guys aren't hitting threes
just comes down to those things we
actually talk about that before the game
you know we're not making shots we got
to find ways to win and
you know i keep saying that it's going
to be on a defensive end and that first
half we gave ourselves
a chance defensively to not be shooting
the ball well but only down six points
and so
we made shots and continue to just push
our pace and do what we do
that the game was going to eventually
turn around for us and it did in that
second half
so does this bode well for a team that
wants to make a deep playoff run and
and more yeah because obviously it's a
bonus when we're making shots
you know our swag is you know way
crazier but i think our spike is even
better
when we're not because we got to guard
and defend and uh you know be on the
page be able to be on the same page
defensively
um you know our antennas go up even more
when we're not making shots
thank you
james what's it like there early in the
first or the fourth quarter rather
where uh you're on the bench and and uh
your guys are able to go on that big run
i think it was 15-0 run unbelievable man
that's
that was a game right there you know the
guys just took it upon themselves to
guard
and uh you know we felt in the sense of
oklahoma city was getting tired and we
just
we kept pressing the pressing gas on
them you know and uh you know that was
that was again game changer right there
for us
uh you know hugh shout out to d house
and jeff tuck
you know all the guys i was in and that
uh in that fourth quarter gordon
uh made some made some big plays
defensively and then made some big shots
taylor brooks hey james so obviously you
are a guy in the league that is very
hard to defend
so much so that charles barkley said
that you were the best one-on-one
you know player that he had seen did you
see that what was your response to it
and why do you think he feels that way
about your game
uh no i haven't seen it i haven't seen
it but uh i just work so hard on my
craft
you know uh day in and day out you know
i can't get tired of it
of the work that i put in you know and
obviously no nights like tonight is
it's great for me you know it humbles me
um because i know that i can do so much
more
and if i'm not making shots and i got to
find other ways to impact the game but
uh more times than not i'm going to be
making shots and i'm going to get to my
spot so
i just got to keep putting the work in
keep chipping away and uh
you know hopefully i have better games
hey james when you're in isolation and
they're throwing all these defenses at
you and overloading you
it's all about making reads um how would
you would you say you guys are as in
sync as you've been all year
yeah especially you know i think we only
had maybe 10 or 12 games something like
that when we
after we traded for uh verkhov you know
so we never really got a chance to catch
a rhythm
um but this you know practices and and
kind of training him
and the eight regular season games gave
us an opportunity to kind of
you know fill out what we had you know
on both ends of the floor so
as far as our spacing uh who set screens
and things like that
it's something that we really dialed in
on and um
you know it's paid off for us matt muesl
mike said earlier hey without fans we
have to generate
our own enthusiasm that seems to be
working very well could you comment
on the enthusiasm that you share for one
another
we feed off each other and you know you
know throughout the entire game
in front of me from the jump ball we got
to give each other encouragement and
energy
and i think even when things aren't
going well we kind of keep giving each
other
that boost of confidence uh you know
because our shots are going to fall and
defensively we're going to be active so
uh courage and confidence goes a long
way you know so we just try to spread
that amongst ourselves
uh amongst our you know teammates and
coaches and uh they give they feed us
back to us so
it goes a long way especially here with
other fans
terence harris hey james how's it going
what's up hey what is it what has it
been like for you to watch
some of the guys that are quote-unquote
role players really be able to step
up in these first two games and just
what does that mean to you as
as one of the you know one of the
leaders of this team to see those kind
of performances
coming from so many different directions
uh we've all seen it throughout the
course of you know playoffs and
and as you get deeper you need you know
you need your team
you know you need guys to play well you
need guys to make big shots make big
plays
uh defensively and offensively and just
tonight was a start
you know and it's been that way you know
guys have been making plays and
been playing pretty well tonight we just
uh you know i wasn't playing well so
you know i didn't shoot the ball well so
uh you know it just looked like it was
it was it was more highlighted but
guys and my teammates have been playing
well all year you know they've been
after it
um and you know tonight was a huge for
us
we'll take two more andres lopez
thank you uh james we were looking at
russell westbrook on the sidelines
all in all not to take away from the
great effort that you guys put in but
how much of today's victory do you
attribute to the energy you get from
russell
on the sidelines and his involvement in
the game i mean
it was our whole team like i said before
we feed off each other so
you know obviously russell gave us that
energy but our entire bench was you know
was
excited and turned up you know
especially when we went on that run
uh and they saw us they saw us excited
so they looking at us
and we're giving them that confidence
and their energy they just gonna keep
you out there and doing what they're
doing so
it was a beautiful sight to see and uh
like i said before
we all give each other that confidence
and that and that uh that courage to go
out there and just be ourselves
the last one simon only
james uh two games then you've gotten
good scoring contributions from daniel
house
eric gordon jeff green and others is
this kind of what you want when you're
missing russ
yeah this is that yeah even with russ
back this is what's gonna have to happen
for us to um you know we our offense is
so spread out you know you got
driving lanes and you got you know we
have shooters you know on the floor so
uh guys any given night guys are going
to be able to you know step up and make
big shots make big plays and
it was a few guys last game it was a few
guys tonight and it's going to
need to be a few guys every single game
for us to have a chance
thank you james thanks